Hi, my name is Zach and I'm a security associate at Portzviga.
Let's be honest, when most of us see WebSocket in a target, it gets less attention than the rest of the application.
But what if we treated it as any other attack service? What cool vulnerabilities you might have uncovered?
Today I'm super excited to introduce you the new version of WebSocket Turbo Intruder
and show you how its new cool features helps you to find new vulnerabilities.
The reason why WebSocket testing is so hard is not because our traditional tools are poorly designed.
They do an excellent job for HTTP. But WebSocket, in a nutshell, is a different kind.
It uses stateful connection, whereas in HTTP you send a request and get a response.
Of course, if you're not using the connection keep alive.
You also should take care about all of the protocol messages like PIN, PONG, CLOSED MESSAGE, etc.
So, let's dive into the WebSocket protocol itself.
It all starts with the HTTP handshake. After that, the connection keeps alive and the protocol itself switches to an entire different framework.
So, there are a couple of the frame types, including the ping-pongs.
But what's different with WebSocket is that the client and the server can send the messages anytime.
And if your tool can't pair these messages, you will miss the important vulnerabilities.
To handle this problem, WebSocket Turbo Intruder introduced the simple integer counter that counts all outgoing and incoming frames.
However, this simple approach has one big limitation. All the WebSocket services have broadcast messages.
And if your tool is not able to filter out the boring content, your testing will fail.
To help you with that, we introduce the new Python decorators that will help you to match the outgoing and ongoing messages.
We also allow you to use a new engine that will help you to exploit unknown vulnerabilities.
So, under the hood, you can right now download the WebSocket Turbo Intruder through the B App Store or through the source code and build if you really want to.
As the original tool created by the James Kettle, WebSocket Turbo Intruder uses the same approach.
We put all the chunks frames into the big chunk of the messages and send them as soon as possible to the web server.
And we never wait the reply. That makes it so extremely fast.
We also use the filter tools to filter out all the boring contexts.
It also inherits all the black-slash-powered scanners to filter out the repeated contents.
You also can use any advanced features like HTTP adapter to use the vulnerability scanning.
It also comes with the command line interface. I will talk about it later.
If you are not familiar with Turbo Intruder, it uses the Python 2 script that allows you to create literally any attack.
You should identify three main functions.
First, QWebSockets allows you to create the connection using one of three supported engines.
First is Burp, RockSolid engine that you usually use during your pen test using the Burp Suite.
Second one is Turbo that we just released for this tool.
It allows you to craft any WebSocket frame, including the male-formed one.
I will show you later on how we can craft the WebSocket frames that will cause the denial of the service.
And also it supports the threaded engine, perfect for the large-scale and fuzzing attacks, including the password brute force.
The two other functions, HandleOutgoingMessage and HandleIncomingMessage,
is pretty simple functions that are responsible for adding results to the table.
So that's pretty much it of the theory. Let's have a look how we're gonna use it.
For the demo, I will use the Avasp Dem-Vulnerable WebSocket labs.
We will start with the brute force attack and the threaded engine.
The lab itself is pretty simple.
We will go to the brute force lab and try to login with invalid credentials for the admin user.
As we might see, we're not able to identify the password.
But if you go to the WebSocket history, you will see that it uses the basic CFO encoding to send the password attempts.
Then you right-click on any WebSocket message in our case, login, and send it to the intruder tool.
On the left side, you will see the message we highlight that will be replaced with the placeholder.
On the right side, you see the initial handshake.
And then you choose it from the library.
I will use the brute force example for that case.
As I said, we will use the threaded engine to open 10 simultaneously WebSocket connections to the target
and basics if I encode the passwords.
I will add all the outgoing messages to the table and only interesting one to the results.
That's pretty easy.
You can do with the tool.
Then you just click the attack button and it will do all the hard work for you.
On the left side, you can see the results table.
As I said, it will add all the outgoing frames to this.
It will show you the outgoing frame or the so-called request pane.
That's of course not the real request, it's just outgoing frame.
And response is incoming frame.
Also, the tool supports any useful metadata like ID, direction, message length, time, etc.
You can sort all of the columns right now.
On the button of the pane, you can see the progress bar where all our frames shown was already been sent.
If we scroll down to the button, you will see only one incoming message.
That is really interesting for us because it has different response that is saying we were able successfully identify the password.
It's still Base64 encoded so we can decode it and see this is just an admin.
Next, I want to show you something that's almost impossible with traditional tools.
Race conditions.
Race conditions often occurs when multiple clients try to change the same data.
We will explore today the time to check, time to use vulnerability in a race condition.
Don't be afraid if you're not familiar with the Python.
With the built-in race condition example, you barely need to change this to exploit the vulnerability.
First, you specify the interval where all our messages should be sent, the number of threads.
Of course, you want to use the ping to warm up the connection so they land as close as possible.
And use the chunks to hit at the same time.
Let's go for the example.
For the demo, I created the Java WebSocket implementation that uses the ID that restricts us to update the data with a different ID.
First, I will show you how it should work.
We reset the ID to the 0 and then send the status update request.
As you might see, it was successfully updated with the ID 0.
But what if we will send the same request using the multiple simultaneous connections?
Let's give it a try.
We will reset our ID and open the race condition example.
As I said, it's barely need to be changed.
So you just select from the library
and click the attack button.
And then we will see the same response.
All scripts include the documentation.
If you would like to, you can read inside of the GitHub repo.
So I'm using the same approach like sending 10ms timeframe of the 10 threads simultaneously to the target.
You just click the attack button and observe the discrepancies.
Right now, because we don't use the interesting response, we will see all the incoming frames.
If you will pay close attention, you will see the ID changed unpredictably.
It might be 1, 3, 5, etc.
As a pen tester, when you see such a discrepancy,
it highlights that the server might be vulnerable to this time to use race condition.
You can exploit such kind of vulnerabilities for the password reset or coupon redeem in our academy labs.
While preparing for the race condition, I discovered an interesting denial of service vulnerability in Java WebSocket implementation.
What if you really want to go wild and exploit low-level vulnerabilities inside the WebSocket?
I mean send any WebSocket frame, including the mail-formed one.
According to the RFC, WebSocket frame starts with the header, specifying the opcode and payload length and only then followed by the payload itself.
With Turbo Engine, you can send any frame time, including text one, and then empty body and really huge payload length.
That value is so huge that it won't fit inside the Python.
That's why I'm using the string literals to be parsed for the long value.
But instead of sending the gigabytes data to the server, we will just send one small tiny packet and see how it will work on the Java Web implementation.
So we will start with the same lab because it's using the Java Web.
And instead of running the race conditions, we will send this tiny mail-formed frame to the server.
You go to the intruder, select the ping of death script and send it to the server.
So what's happened under the hood?
Java reads the opcode and then follow up the payload length.
The payload length is so huge that the Java failed to allocate the buffer and failed, crushing the virtual machine.
If you will click the attack button, the server won't reply for any further questions.
WebSocket Turbo Intruder allows you to see the all closed error frames too, so it won't get you unnoticed.
Now let's try to reconnect to the server.
We won't be able to do this anymore because server crashed.
What if you want to use Burp Suite Scanner or any other HTTP Web tool to test your Web circuits?
Traditionally, it's not possible.
You need to manually translate messages or write a custom plugin.
With HTTP middleware, you can now use the WebSocket Turbo Intruder to wrap all your WebSocket connections into the HTTP post messages.
It's using the same approach and same three functions.
First, create the connection.
You create connection using one of the supported engines.
And then handle incoming messages.
You also can use the filters to highlight only interesting responses.
Let's give it an action.
For the demo, I will use the SQL injection vulnerability from the Demn Vulnerable WebSocket Labs.
We will go to the error SQL injection and try to send quotes to the server.
Sending the quote and single quote will return two different error messages.
One showing the incorrect password and second one showing the error on the server side.
As I said, all of them will be Base64 encoded.
This highlights that the server might be vulnerable to the SQL injection.
To exploit it, we will use the HTTP middleware.
You right-click, select extension and HTTP middleware.
In most cases, you will need just a simple server example that will wrap the WebSocket connection.
You can select any URL you select and the upgrade request.
That's pretty it.
You just click the start of the server.
It will listen for the 9000 port and all the incoming post messages will be wrapped into the WebSocket and sent to the server.
On the right pane, you see the table of requests.
Then we will select the first post request and send it to the repeater to reproduce the normal connection.
Now we can see that the WebSocket replies.
I will use the SQL map to test for the SQL injection vulnerabilities and Base64 temper script to Base64 encode all our payloads.
As soon as the extension finds the vulnerability, you will see them in the issue map.
I will use the last one that will turn our error SQL injection into the message.
Once again, it should be Base64 encoded to successfully reproduce the issue.
You can send to the repeater, pass it into the password and encode.
Then we send to the server and observe this. Vulnerability was confirmed.
What if your target requires advanced client configuration?
WebSocket Turbo Intruder can help with that too.
For the demo, we will take a look on Socket.io.
Socket.io is a JavaScript framework.
It uses WebSocket as just the network layer.
Above of it, it uses the Engine.io.
And above of that, it's using the Socket.io.
That's a huge stack of technologies creates the real big difficulties to test this kind of web servers.
To help you with that, I create a special sample script that will handle all the Socket.io discrepancies.
It also automatically hand all the pin and pawn messages using the decorators,
so you don't have to worry about all the reconnection.
It will allow you to keep the state and exploit more complex vulnerabilities.
To demo the vulnerability, I will use a really nice gadget.
For those of you who are not familiar with the Gareth research on exploiting server-side prototype pollution,
I really recommend you to take a look on the original blog post.
We will be using the same approach.
Because of the server-side prototype pollution nature,
it's usually really hard to identify that vulnerability literally works.
To work up this limitation, we will use the initial packet.
So, how it works?
When the client connects to the server,
the server will reply with the initial packet
if it was specified under the options.
Using the server-side prototype pollution,
we will inject this initial packet into our prototype object.
This will help us to identify the vulnerability.
Let's see its connection.
First, you have to send the 4-0 message to the server to say that the connection was established.
To do this, we will just go to the HTTP middleware and paste the socket.io script.
It will do all the hard work for us, including the switching to the engine.io level 4.
That won't require us to do all the hard work.
And then, you just send the post messages and observe that it tries to parse the JSON.
The Turbo Intruder also includes the logger capabilities, so you will be able to debug all your sessions.
Let's go back to the repeater and try to exploit the server-side prototype pollution.
As I said, if the server incorrectly merge two objects and pollute the Proto object, we won't be able to observe the result.
But when we reconnect, we will see the initial message saying that it was successfully polluted.
WebSocket Turbo Intruder also includes a standalone Scylla-i tool, ideal for automation and scripting.
For the demo, I will use the us command injection from the DemVulverable WebSocket Labs.
It has a pretty basic support right now, so if you would like to test more sophisticated attacks, I would recommend to use the Burpsuite interface.
But if you just want to run a really long attack, it might be better to use the standalone tool.
First, you specify the script.py, the Python script file, then request, the target, and the placeholder.
Let's see in an action.
Command-injection lab is a pretty simple one.
It uses pin command to ping any host you specify on the target.
So for the demo, we will use the localhost, confirm that the lab works correctly.
Then we will go to the Scylla-i and try to exploit using the list of webroot.
Let's take a look on basic example.
We will send ampersand sign and then the list directory.
You hit the start button and when the new frame will come, you will see the results.
It will also save all the results to the results.json file, so you won't miss an incoming frame.
The incoming frames will be base64 encoded, so you can decode them using one of the tools.
In our case, we'll go to the Burpsuite, decode, and see the root directory.
I hope today's demo inspires you to start giving WebSocket the attention they deserve.
With WebSocket Burntruder, you can extend your attack surface and detect previously unknown vulnerabilities.
That's the end of our today's demo.
Download the extension from the GitHub or the B-App Store.
If you find a really cool use case or create a nice server script example, share it with using the pull request or create a new issue.
Thank you very much. If you have any feedback, feel free to share it with me using the Google Forms.